"What?"
Asked Curious Cat.
"What is for breakfast?"
"Fish,"
Said Mother Cat.
"What is for morning snack?"
Asked Curious Cat.
Mother Cat said.
"Fish."
"What can I have for lunch?"
Asked Curious Cat.
"Fish is for lunch,"
Said Mother Cat.
"What is for afternoon snack?"
Asked Curious Cat.
"Fish,"
Said Mother Cat.
"What are we having for dinner?"
asked Curious Cat.
"For dinner we are having fish,"
Said Mother Cat.
"Fish, fish, fish,"
Said Curious Cat.
"All we have is fish."
"Please, please can I have pizza?
No more fish, please,"
said Curious Cat.
What do you have for breakfast?
I have rice for breakfast.
What does your sister have for lunch?
She has sandwiches for lunch.
Does your mom have rice for dinner?
No, she doesn't. She doesn't have dinner.